- One summer I realized, you know what,
I think Khan Academy actually
has all of this for me.
So I spent the summer looking at it
and I had two algebra classes,
and I used one for like
completely Kahn Academy.
I want you guys to watch the
videos, do all the quizzes,
homework, tests, and
we're gonna see how it is.
And the other class I
taught from the front
and did my traditional
lesson plans like that.
And it was pretty evident by Christmas
that the kids that were able to, you know,
that I was able to move around
and not teach from the front.
Those kids were advancing more.
Once I get going, it's
like I'm helping this kid,
and I'm helping this kid, and
you know, kids are waiting,
and so then all of a sudden
they're starting to help each other,
and it's just like this Socratic method,
that is just, it's amazing to watch.
And I get goosebumps every
time I think about it.
And I realize that as a tiny school,
and being the only math teacher,
it gives me that flexibility.
But I think, you know, with
just a little bit of creativity,
I think bigger schools
could do the same thing,
because it's still all in
their Khan Academy account.
It's documented that they've learned it,
that they've mastered it.
Kids that just spent 20 minutes a day,
averaged an 80% or above,
80%, it was unbelievable.